la carte du nucléaire en france
aujourd'hui demain la voici sont en
service les centrales des monts d'arrée
du loir-et-cher d'indre-et-loire des
ardennes de l'ain et du gard 12
milliards de kilowattheures en 73 soit
presque 9 % de la production nationale
ne figure sur cette carte ni les
installations militaires ni le réacteur
expérimental phoenix en construction les
deux tranches de fessenheim deux autres
à bugey chaque tranche désignant un
réacteur et tout son installation
trois autres centrales seront renforcées
deux tranches supplémentaires à bugey
deux autres à saint laurent des eaux
une extension à chinon la totalité des
sites nucléaires d'ici à 80 est connu
gravelines de une à six tranches
palluel de une à quatre une dans l'aude
une sur la gironde une a4 dans le loiret
4 dans la drôme pour l' usine européenne
d'enrichissement de l'uranium et un sur
régénérateur européen dans l'isère on
laisse entendre pour l'instant que cette
carte est définitive qu'il n'y aura pas
d'autres sites nucléaires
les mises en chantiers auront donc lieu
à partir de cette année au rythme de six
à sept centrales par an et ce jusque
vers les années 80 même dans l'hypothèse
où il n'y aurait pas de problème de
financement
chaque tranche coûte un milliard deux
cents millions de francs lourd
l'effort demandé est techniquement à la
limite des possibilités de l'industrie
française
quant au but visé par les pouvoirs
publics en fonçant dans l'ère nucléaire
il est le suivant en 1980 le nucléaire
doit couvrir 23% de la demande
électrique en 85 50 % à la fin du siècle
près de 90 % étant donné le délai de six
ans entre mises en chantier est mise en
service notre dépendance à l'égard du
pétrole arabe ou non ne diminuera
qu'après 1980
dans l'état actuel de la société
industrielle et de ses techniques il n'y
avait apparemment pas d'autre choix que
le nucléaire faute de quoi la machine
industrielle se casseraient
le pari nucléaire est au moins double
primo les techniques sont américaines
secundo l'uranium enrichi indispensable
à ces techniques est lui aussi américain
ces deux fêtes hypothèque singulièrement
l'idée même d'indépendance
celle-ci cette indépendance ne serait
effective qu'après 1980 lorsque l' usine
d'enrichissement de l'uranium de
tricastin aura commencé à produire
on compte aussi sur la technique des
surrégénérateurs qui théoriquement
résoudrait tout problème de rendement et
d'approvisionnement cela dit pour ne pas
risquer en l'an 2000 ou avant d'être
dans une situation analogue à celle
d'aujourd'hui c'est-à-dire une
dépendance quasi totale à l'égard non
plus du pétrole mais de l'atome et de
ses dangers éventuels
il convient dès aujourd'hui de
rechercher des sources d'énergie non
nucléaires il faut en somme aujourd'hui
préparer la relève du nucléaire
[Musique]